whispers games later
[Music]
three rebounds nine point lead early and
fall nails Supreme Court immersed his
first couple long no hesitation knocks
down another back-to-back threes for
ronzo whole heart going against capella
ball tries another three got it on so
ball is in his last three from downtown
of the Lakers take the lead in its
number four all China knocking away ten
Kuzma fall left wide open it's a frame
ball 4 for 7 from downtown he's got 14
points there night after starting the
season with a ton 56 and two games
LeBron kick it Lonzo first shot deep
bent down what a way to start the game
green up a Laker eight assists on there
14 baskets open their descent fighting
large or to shoot the crowd on an
authority
he hesitated at first main weapons so
far tonight has been to three-point shot
begin knocking it down LeBron 10 on the
clock of agreement it's an OT lonzo's
going to try it
I like him he doesn't hesitate howdy
and that's what course the miss by
DeRozan lawns although the kit
[Applause]
James moving downhill at the Lonzo ball
receiving and have a retooled shooting
stroke there from Alonzo Paul what's
that I don't know where
[Applause]
where he from poaching free-to-play
that's right here
[Applause]